j'avais promis de venir dans nos outre
mer j'avais promis de venir dans nos
outre mer parce que vous savez que je
suis l'héritière de jacques chirac et
que jacques chirac y voyait la france en
grand la france ensemble et la france en
grand cet in france qui fait toute sa
place à nos outre mer je vais être la
candidate du pouvoir d'achat et la
question du pouvoir d'achat dans nos
outre-mer elle est vraiment importante
vraiment importante parce que vous avez
des petits salaires et vous avez les
prix les plus chers donc nous mettrons
points avec l'état un panier de 600
produits de première nécessité dont nous
contrôlerons les prix parce que ça n'est
pas normal qu'aujourd'hui tout soit
beaucoup plus cher alors il ya plein de
tarifs qui va falloir renégocier les
tarifs bancaires les tarifs postaux les
tarifs des billets d'avion et puis les
abonnements de téléphone et d'internet
ça n'est pas normal que tout soit plus
cher ici chez vous voilà c'est
inadmissible c'est une double peine
avec 30% des guadeloupéens qui vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté
ça n'est pas possible
état fera une aide au transport de
marchandises et l'état pèsera de tout
son poids dans la négociation de ses
tarifs et puis il va falloir revoir le
dispositif de l'octroi de mer parce que
le dispositif de l'octroi de mer fait
que tous les produits qui vous arrive
ils sont plus chers qu'ailleurs alors
que l'octroi de mer est là pour protéger
les productions de la guadeloupe donc
nous obtiendrons auprès de bruxelles la
révision de l'octroi de mer vous l'avez
compris je suis la candidate du pouvoir
d'achat mais je suis surtout la
candidate du pouvoir être debout vivre
debout voilà comme dit comme on dit en
créole on dit quoi on dit - c'est une
femme doubout tu sais ça
[Applaudissements]